- I have to get shots.
I'm going to Ghana.
I don't want shots!
("Unstoppable" by This Is Wolff)
("What I Am" by Luke O'Brien)
Wednesday morning
busy, busy day.
I'm supposed to be
in L.A., got canceled,
so loaded up the Cali
instead of going to Cali.
You know last time
we hung, we were like,
"Hey, let's really try to do
this at least once a quarter."
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Gary] I really,
really want to use this.
I had him book it in already
for the rest of the year.
It's just important.
- [Man] Yeah. I agree, man.
- [Gary] Just important.
- [Man] I agree.
I have to get shots.
I'm going to Ghana.
I don't want shots.
Big win last night.
- Big win last night.
- You needed that.
- How you doing?
- Good, man.
- What's up, Ty?
- What a great character.
Ty, can I walk you
through this real quick?
- [Tyler] Yeah.
- This is the big one.
- Those the shots you need?
- Yeah. This is the big one.
Address. Where do I live?
Hey, bro. How are you?
Good to see you.
- You?
- Good.
- I was here like
"What?" Got it. That's good.
- And he hit him up?
- I know Just had
been talking on it.
- Yeah exactly. So he hit me up
- And he did that...
- And then... and
then I sent 'im this
- And then I saw this.
And wrote that...
- Good, Good. Good.
- Good to see ya
- Yeah likewise. How's things?
- Very simply, I just
think you're a great dude,
and I just want you to,
macro is a piece of cake--
- Yes.
- 60 days from now is
a foregone conclusion.
- Right.
- What I like about the way
I think about the world, is
if I can bring
value in those 60,
like I'm not like "Oh,
this will be fine in 60 days"
- Right, right.
- I'm kinda like, if I can
make it from a 6.3 to a 7.1
in those 60 days, well
then let me hear it.
- [Man 2] I think, yeah,
it's just some
people don't have that
that outside, let's say...
- Oh, I get it man
- [Man 2] That
experience to understand
how real what
you're saying is. You know?
- [Gary] It's very simple.
- If you play the
chess game out,
If I'm sitting her with
(censored) like, here's your
data and she's like,
"Well, I didn't trust it."
I'm like, "Then you
shouldn't work here."
- [Man 3] Yeah.
- If you don't trust
the machine that goes to me,
well then,
what're we doing here?
People do things now,
just to PR themselves.
- [Lee] Yeah.
- People literally go hiking,
38 people here will go hiking
(Gary laughs)
38 people will go hiking
in my office this weekend.
They'll drive an hour and a
half out to upstate New York
just for the Instagram shot.
Have you been to the
meditation studio on twenty?
Can you send him
the info right now?
I want you to go
and check it out.
I'd love to get your opinion.
- Want me to
give you a meditation?
- Yeah. Let's do it.
- So, here's how easy it is.
It uses the acronym SHERPA.
- SHERPA. Go ahead.
- It's gonna go through
S-H-E-R-P-A
- Let's do it. You ready, Nate?
- I'm ready.
- So feet on the floor,
close our eyes.
(gong reverberating)
- So
"S" is "Shhhh"
It's a hard thing to
get to, that quietness.
Sometimes I just see
the black of my eyes.
Eyelids.
"H" is "Here"
You don't have to
say it. Just think it.
So it's "H-E-R-E".
Just try and be here.
And in New York, it's "H-E-A-R"
Let the noises not bother you,
but let them bring you here.
Just be here right now.
Take a few breaths with that.
"E" is "Experience".
Experience your body.
If you need to sit up,
and get your posture right.
"R" is "Realize"
Realize how good
things are right now.
We're not in a
dangerous situation.
Just realize where we are.
"P" is "Purpose".
It could be your
purpose for today,
it could be a bigger purpose.
Just take a few breaths,
and remind
yourself of your purpose.
"A" is "Action"
Just think of one step
that you're gonna take next,
to satisfy your
purpose and move forward.
See it.
Then let's take
action and open our eyes.
(gong reverberating)
- That's awesome.
- It was good.
- It is good. I'm really,
I'm a big believer
I think that mental
health, mental fitness,
meditation, it's gonna
be the whole thing.
- Yeah.
- And it's gonna be good.
- It doesn't have to be like
this Kumbaya stuff, like ...
- No, no, no. I mean...
- I do this before a
meeting that I'm about to...
You know? Just to...
- Oh I have...
I would tell you,
50% of my friends
are hard core deep.
- Yeah.
- One thing I live about
my life as a businessman,
is I don't wanna be
at the mercy of anybody.
I love that everybody
can leave, and I feel okay.
At a micro,
I don't want there to be
four people that can do TV,
or seven people that can,
I don't like that feeling,
and I like stretching it out.
Hey eerybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 249
of The #AskGaryVee Show!
Here's the one
thing I can promise you.
You need to work
you're fucking face off,
and, nobody gives a
shit about where you grew up.
Nobody's gonna feel
sorry for you circumstantially,
or feel positive for you,
whether you're
born in the ghetto
or you're born to a trust fund,
at the end of the day,
once you hit the real world
nobody cares,
'cause then the clock's on.
If you're a trust fund baby,
people are judging you
like, "You suck. It's
all 'cause of your daddy."
If you're fuckin'
from the ghetto, it's like
"You have no shot.
You don't look the part."
Either way, nobody cares.
The end, the only thing that
you should be figuring out
is what are you good at?
And so you should try
a lotta shit, right?
And, then you need
to work every minute.
Like, if you're not
gonna go to college,
you're gonna
have to work, right?
Like, if you're not gonna
use the brand of the degree
and before MissionU mean
something to the whole world,
you're gonna have
to work, and prove it.
- I like it.
- I love you brother.
- I love you too, man.
- Adam Braun.
You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
It's funny. I never
had anything happen.
I tore my meniscus
five years ago, seven, no
eight years ago,
playing basketball.
Didn't even really know.
I tore the other meniscus?
Like, when you do
something, I'm like ...
As I was falling, I'm like,
"Tore my meniscus!",
like literally!
("Whatever You Like" by Tryce)
What I like, is that people
think that this is the empire?
And I think this is like...
You know when your table is
wobbling? At a restaurant?
And they come over
and slide a piece of wood
to make it stable?
- [Woman] Yep.
- That's literally how
I think of this company.
That I think it's
just a piece of wood.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- And that excites me.
That I know we've
built something meaningful,
that it's doing great
- [Woman] And
totally independently--
- Yes. But that it's
a proxy to my bigger thoughts.
I'm funny, right? Like, my
best day the other day was,
I was playing my kids in
basketball in the living room
two-on-one to five.
I let them go up four
nothing, and then I beat them.
- Yeah.
- And when I hit the
game-winner,
they collapsed into crying
like deep crocodile tears.
- Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
- I was pumped.
- (laughs) I love that.
- I think that matters.
And by the way, my son
has more toys right now,
my son gets more toys in a
month, than I had in my life.
- Right.
- Do you wanna
hear how weird it is?
Now you're gonna get a, your
first real insight in to me.
Your first real, real one.
I am fearful, that
I'm doing it on purpose,
to not let them
be hungrier than me.
- Thank you.
- That was fun.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- It's the context of the
religion of the distribution.
The reason I make content,
that always tends to
have a better chance,
is my creative can literally
be a four to your nine,
every time, but when
my distribution is a ten
to the market zero,
I don't wanna use your,
I'm just in the game.
I'm literally predicting...
I looked at DRock yesterday,
and said I just
made a viral video.
And it went viral
yesterday. Like, I know.
Check this out.
A friend of mine
form the liquor business
texts me, "Congrats on China."
I write "?. Not
sure what that means.
"Love you. How you feelin'?"
He goes,
"Trying to walk" ...
he's not feeling well ...
"A friend of mine said" ...
" A friend of mine in China,
"said you were getting
your name out there."
("Power" by Duo)
Guys, thanks for all your help.
Cheers. Cheers. Cheers.
Cheers. Cheers. Nazdrave.
- What is that?
- Nazdrave. It's Russian.
"To good health."
I'm out.
- [Man 3] Please don't
tell me it's the first time
you've ever had one?
- [DRock] No.
- See ya.